mais avec nous ce soir jérôme marty
médecins généralistes bonsoir j'ai
remarqué vous est aussi président de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre vos côtés philippe poteau ce
directeur de l'office du tourisme de la
station les carreaux située en haute
savoie près de la frontière suisse
bonsoir à vous aussi arnaud benedetti un
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire
bonsoir a tous des trois merci d'être
avec nous alors avant d'évoquer les
mesures contre le virus la question des
vaccins arnaud benedetti emmanuel macron
on l'a vu lors d'une visite à des
étudiants s'est plaint face aux
critiques de mauvaise gestion de la
crise de la part des français nous
sommes devenus une nation de 66 millions
de procureur at il dit
le président qu'elle fait l'apologie du
droit à se tromper une réaction
d'observateurs politiques que vous êtes
le droit se tromper doit être assortie
aussi du droit à la critique
ce qui me paraît tout à fait légitime
dans une démocratie moi je suis assez
surpris voire déstabilisé par cette
déclaration du président de la
république qui intervient dans un
instant où l'on prépare finalement la
société française à subir de nouvelles
contraintes en raison de la crise
salutaire au moment où finalement on se
rend compte que l'opinion publique y est
relativement disons calme voire résigné
même presque à accepter un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont tous les
jours un peu plus contraignantes ses
déclarations du président de la
république constitue à mon sens une
erreur de communication
parce que tout simplement elles
traduisent finalement une tension
permanente que le président exerce dans
sa relation avec le corps social à un
moment où finalement le corps social a
besoin surtout à la fois d'explication
de pédagogie et d'apaisement compte tenu
de la situation sanitaire
donc tout se passe finalement comme si
le président n'avait pas appris de ses
erreurs de communication passée lors
d'autres crises je pense notamment à la
clint gilet jaune et je crois que en
effet cette dernière sortie du chef de
l'état n'est pas en mesure d'une
certaine manière disons de rassurer
l'opinion publique sur sa façon de
concevoir sa relation à l'opinion
publique au delà de la crise sanitaire
seulement le sujet la clé sanitaire qui
que pose que que qui pose question dans
cette dans cette déclaration c'est
plutôt tout simplement la communication
politique du chef de l'état alors on
lisait un la menace d'un troisième
confinement est sur toutes les lèvres et
notamment celle de l'exécutif une mesure
inutile selon eric chabrière professeur
en biochimie allez y et du pardon
militaire année proche collaborateur du
didier raoul qu'il était l'invité
d'hervé france se met à écouter le
confinement n'a pas montré son
efficacité et je pense que la
démonstration la plus forte c'est pour
l'automne uni le couvre-feu dans les
départements avec ou sans couvre feu
nous ont montré leur efficacité ou leurs
différences et en plein milieu du
confinement
le nombre de baisses de contamination a
stagné
il n'a pas vraiment repris non plus à la
fin du confinement
donc je pense que ces mesures sont
inutiles ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que derrière les vétérinaires qui
ont l'habitude de gérer des crises
épidémique dans les élevages
il ne confirme pas leurs animaux
ensemble ça ne marche pas on isole les
animaux malades pour les soigner nous on
a une approche complètement différente
de bloquer les gens les gens peuvent se
contaminer à la maison cette semaine
j'étais à paris dans les transports en
commun qui était bondé
voilà on va dire les gens c'est
difficile d'arrêter une épidémie et
c'est illusoire de croire qu'en laissant
les gens plus longtemps à la maison que
ça va se tromper
dr marty alors qu'effectivement ce
deuxième confinement montré ses limites
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
quand on parle comme ça de 3e
confinement quel est votre avis de
médecins ce qu'il faut à confiner ou
laisser plus de liberté aux français
aujourd'hui
il ya plusieurs choses dans votre
question d'abord le confinement a montré
son efficacité
le seul problème c'est qu'il ne s'est
pas sorti dès les séries
une curée permis de poursuivre son
efficacité c'est à dire que quand on a
enlevé en particulier le deuxième
élément on était déjà trop en termes de
plateau on n'a pas voulu s'attaquer au
lait matic des écoles c'est à dire le
pas fermé évidemment les écoles mais
agir sur les counting qui sont de
véritables incubateurs virale on n'a pas
voulu s'attaquer aux chefs d'entreprise
qui sont également des incubateurs et on
a en quelque sorte comme pony toutes les
mesures qu'elle puisse parler français
qui respecte ces mesures qu'il faut
saluer on a tamponné avec les arrivées
virale qui venait d écoles d et donc on
a eu un plateau de qualité bil bil toki
aujourd'hui et à 26000 qui continuent à
décoller tranquillement on est plutôt
mieux placé que les pays peu d'autres
pays européens qui notamment lors des
vacances de noël ont réouvert les
peuples vers l'est
les toutous s'inquiéter de ce qui était
pas l'accepter et qui aujourd'hui ont
des chiffres plus élevés je pense à
l'angleterre ou l'irlande par exemple et
puis on a cette problématique de
variants qui accélère de plus en plus
qui risque de prendre place
mathématiquement du virus qui est sur
notre territoire entre eux allez le 15e
du 15 février au 30 mars dans la
situation la plus pessimiste est puis
fin mars à la situation un petit peu
plus optimistes mais qui nous impose
d'être beaucoup plus efficace alors tout
le monde de créer un confinement d'un
nouveau confinement parce que les
conséquences sociales sociétales
économiques sont extrêmement importantes
de plus en plus importante confinement
après confinement mais on voit bien que
malheureusement dans certains
départements on a on est en train de
vivre des choses qu'on n'avait jamais
rencontré jusqu'à présent avec des
accélérations de nombre de cas d'un
certain dépendent en particulier dans le
sud-est qui sont du domaine quasi de
l'explosion
et donc il faut qu'on regarde ça de
façon extrêmement extrêmement précises
de façon à prendre les mesures taux ne
pas attendre trop et nous on prône
plutôt si c'est un couvre-feu commis les
faits il doit s'accompagner de mesures
sur les cantines sur les surprises comme
en parler et si on va en confinement
alors là il faut sans doute plutôt viser
un confinement européen c'est à dire
qu'on ferme tous en même temps
convaincre
très vite pendant ce temps de
confinement et qu'on puisse en faire et
ouvrir avec en quelque sorte un des
compteurs à zéro plutôt qu'à voir ce
qu'on a connu depuis le début un pays
qui ferme et décalés ou alors ce qui
fait notre mouvement et le virus qui
circule comme s'adonnant à l'autre
semblait effectivement ça semble être un
voeu pieux cher docteur marty parce que
le la même chose dans tous les pays
européens on en est loin et la question
des vaccins on en parlera précisément
avec vous un petit peu plus tard en tout
cas ceux qui veulent retrouver une
activité qui paient un lourd tribut
ce sont les stations ski en certainement
qu'il y aura des confirmations tout à
l'heure au journal de 20 heures deux de
nos confrères de tf1 d'olivier révérence
et stations de ski qui a priori
resteront fermés c'est une saison morte
qui semble pendre au nez de ces
professionnels vous propose tout d'abord
la réaction du syndicat national des
remontées mécaniques et des domaines
skiables avant de vous faire réagir
concernant les remontées mécaniques
le gouvernement n'a pas baser ses
décisions sur des éléments rationnels
mais sur des préjugés de montagne
exubérante et de comportements débridée
loin des réalités des clichés qui prouve
un manque de connaissance et de
confiance
la montagne mettra des années à s'en
remettre 2 mars 2020 à décembre 2021
c'est presque deux ans de fermeture deux
ans sans recette ni trésorerie
les dispositifs d'indemnisation doivent
inclure tous les acteurs des stations
infinie poteau on imagine votre désarroi
aujourd'hui la montagne qui mettra des
années à s'en remettre
comment vous allez faire nous avions
encore un mince espoir jusqu'à ce début
de semaine est là le couperet est tombé
hier de tout état de cause donc on s'en
doutait un petit peu quand même hein les
réseaux mal et la posture de pire à tout
prix il faut ou père en février on
voyait bien le temps on voyait bien le
nombre de personnes contaminées donc il
fallait se rendre à l'évidence que ça
serait très compliqué de peu les
stations ouvrent pas tant que sur le
délicat sur les télésièges on puisse
être distancié mais ces brassages de
population c'est et à mener
des centaines et centaines de milliers
de personnes aux sports d'hiver dans les
magasins hors et on sait que là on ans
le docteur disais tout à l'heure c'est
un lieu d'échangés par rapport au virus
donc c'était ce n'était pas tenable
voilà donc maintenant la décision es
prise ce qui va falloir avoir une
visibilité c'est à dire qu'est-ce qui la
confine man ou pas est ce que les
stations vont ouvrir sans les remontées
mécaniques en février et que on va faire
un produit station or ce qui avec comme
à noël avec autour du ski de fond autour
du ski de randonnée autour de la
raquette
voilà et est-ce qu'on pourra vous être
qu'on va confiné vous à moi si l'on
ouvrait même les remontées mécaniques
maintenant ne jamais on aurait rempli et
au niveau financier économique les
stations se seraient pas retrouvés
aujourd'hui faut discuter des
compensations économie ni faune lutte et
comment compenser cette perte au niveau
des stations de ski mais également des
mre de sport qui n'ont pas eu de
fermeture administrative
donc c'est complexe mais on s'y
attendait vraiment c'est pas une grosse
surprise c'est vrai que la posture de
domaines skiables de france du des
moniteurs des parlementaires était
logique devait se battre jusqu'au bout
mais la décision est plus bien plus haut
il ya des raisons sanitaires connais
personnellement le directeur de d'aidé
d'urgence de chambéry munich le cc à
flux tendu et pas possible donc il faut
se rendre à l'évidence la santé d'abord
c'est sûr c'est atypique on l'a jamais
connu une année blanche comme ça pour
les stations de haute altitude savez
terrible nous les stations villages on
pourra peut-être faire quand même
quelque chose de correct peut-être à -50
et -60%
mais c'est très dur à accepter en tout
cas vous êtes plutôt compréhensifs et
c'est tout à votre honneur jérôme marty
c'était nécessaire cette fermeture parce
que certainement que ces stations elles
vont peut-être restés ouverts on va
peut-être pas empêché voilà des stations
il ya des locations d'appartements de
rester accessible au public les gens
vont quand même se brasser c'est vrai
que quand on voit vous l'avez dit
vous-même certains sont de commerciaux
bondés le samedi après midi on peut se
poser la question on aurait été
peut-être mieux pour certains français
dans la neige avec des masques à prendre
ça fait du bien au moral aussi non non
mais c'est l'évidence mais vous savez
l'économie qui tourne autour du ski
séoul avait très justement dit ses
déplacements de population pas seulement
d'ailleurs de population qui viendra
pour le loisir mais c'est aussi les
déplacements des travailleurs vous allez
quantité de saisonniers qu'il faut
embaucher qu'on va donc passer aussi
vous ouvrez maintenant alors même qu' il
y à une menace de confinement dans
quinze jours vous comprenez aisément que
la chose et est extrêmement difficile et
est quasi impossible
les matières qui se pose est est
particulière nous on défend des la
possibilité puisque je suis innocent
donc kenney défendez la possibilité de
laisser les stations ouvertes à la
journée pour la clientèle régionale
c'est à dire que vous avez un doute et
de ville où les gens vous restiez la
journée ils partent le matin ils
rentrent le sport il ya donc pas d
impact sur les infrastructures
hôtelières avec des risques de
concentration soit des petits
appartements dans plusieurs îles il ya
le sport de plein air on le sait n'est
pas à risque
les contaminations en plein air sont
quasi d'asie extrêmement quel on peut
dire minimale et il existait donc le
vrai risque est effectivement à la
concentration de nos magasins mais vous
l'avez dit les grandes surfaces sont
ouverts tous les centres commerciaux
sont couverts donc avec avec en prenant
les précautions
c'est tout à fait possible mais mais
mais on a ce variant on a à la menace du
confinement et donc on a laissé passer
peut-être le temps où on aurait pu
ouvrir qui était celui de lévis décembre
jusqu'à maintenant et la maintenance est
quasi impossible
arnaud benedetti on a entendu un
philippe pathos plutôt compréhensifs
mais tout de même beaucoup de français
s'interrogent sur cette cohérence des
mesures du gouvernement
encore une fois on vient d'en parler les
centres commerciaux bondés les
restaurants fermés mais les cantines
ouvertes les stations ski fermer
également quand ya quand même certains
échanger notamment dans le sport les
activités sportives à l'extérieur a
paris il ya de la cohérence dans les
décisions du gouvernement selon vous ça
c'est une situation qui est très
difficilement maîtrisable et on s'en
rend compte et où finalement il ya très
peu de visibilité ou les projections
d'un jour sont très souvent infirmée par
les projections du lendemain il est très
difficile pour l'action publique de
bâtir une stratégie qui puisse
apparaître cohérente on voit bien que
finalement toutes ces mesures qui sont
d'ailleurs foncièrement différenciées
les unes des autres qui vise finale va
adapter de manière quasi plastique là là
la réponse publique à l'épidémie
entraîne des incompréhensions vous
l'avez fort justement dit pourquoi il
finit fermé des restaurants et laissé
ouvert des restaurants d'entreprise
pourquoi fermer un certain nombre de
commerces comme ça a été fait lors du
premier confinement et maintenir les
écoles ouvertes et maintenir les métros
bondés qui circulent dont on nous dit
d'ailleurs selon certaines études mais
je ne sais pas lesquels qu'il serait
moins contaminant que les cafés des
restaurants
je crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui une grande
difficulté pour l'action publique de
pouvoir apporter de la cohérence à
l'opinion publique parce que tout
simplement on navigue à vue et on l'a
tous compris eux depuis le début de
cette épidémie on n'est pas les seuls en
l'occurrence manifestement c'est le cas
de la plupart des pays qui sont
confrontés à cette épidémie
mais je crois quand même que sur le fond
il y a un souci c'est à dire que on se
rend bien compte que dans l'histoire
récente toute récente de cette épidémie
ce qui a été le mieux compris depuis le
début c'était le confinement généralisée
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où au
mois de mars lorsque le gouvernement a
décidé à l'instar d'autres d'autres pays
d'avoir un confinement généralisée il y
a eu là de la part de l'opinion publique
une
compréhension de cette mesure
aujourd'hui on a pill otages qui est
encore une fois un allemand et un
pilotage qui ait pu différencier mais on
voit bien et ça ça me semble plus
important c'est que on était en train de
de préparer de conditionner de manière
très suggestive en tout cas l'opinion
publique à un nouveau continent qui à
mon avis aura lieu dans les jours ou en
tout cas dans les semaines qui viennent
en raison notamment de ce nouveau
variant britannique n'est pas le sérieux
si le variant sud africain qui n'a pas
rêvé sang-hwa un certain nombre de
problèmes notamment sur le vaccin
donc on prépare les esprits mais le vrai
problème c'est de savoir quelle sera la
nature de ce continent en continent
numéro 2
plutôt qu'un consentement numéro un je
ne suis pas sûr que là ça soit
véritablement compris là aussi par
l'opinion publique
chacun faisant un usage très personnelle
de se constituer lors de la de la
deuxième phase c'était l'objet de ma
remarque quand j'essayais non non je
vous en prie je vous en prie quel type
de confinement effectivement parce qu à
l'instant à olivier verrons d'ici la
situation se dégrade nous prendrons des
mesures difficiles mais il ne précise
pas lesquels précisément le vaccin
justement vous en parliez olivier vers
en parle aussi puisqu'il admet ce soir
un surbooking ce sont ses mots
en la matière les vaccins jérôme marty
on avait une polémique avec vous un
notamment qu'est en train de naître sur
l'approvisionnement justement du vaccin
fais r vous avez pas de sa coup de
gueule sur twitter propose d'écouter
father biotech se fout bien de notre
gueule vous savez que les médecins de
terrain ont mis en évidence le fait que
l'on pouvait avec du matériel adapté et
une technique protocole is est prélevé
sido à partir d'un flacon annoncé à 5
eh bien le laboratoire a réagi covit 19
fighter considère qu'un flacons de
vaccin contient 6 dose et adapte ses
livraisons
vous n'êtes pas le seul à pousser ce
coup de gueule un d'autres médecins vous
ont rejoints et cette polémique est en
train de monter comme on dit sur les
réseaux sociaux si on comprend bien
jusqu'à récemment le laboratoire livrer
les pays acheteurs sur la base de cinq
doses de vaccins en flacons maintenant
ce sera si ce qu'est ce que ça change
quel est le problème pour d'un qu'on
comprenne énormément de choses ça
changeait la donne change d'abord ça
pose plusieurs questions
effectivement on avait mis à l'évidence
les médecins l'avaient mis à l'évidence
le fait qu'on pouvait faire si doses à
partir de cinq doses de vaccins d'un
site d'un cycle la une et c'est ma
publié cela est indiqué effectivement
c'était exact et donc fraser a saisi la
balle au bond et adib et les contrats
sont basés sur les doses comme vous
pouvez le faire si doses à partir de
notre compte de ces ondes à vous livrer
20 % de très loin ce que ça change c'est
que windows qui était une dose bonus
surnuméraire en quelque sorte que l'on
faisait qui nous permettait de vacciner
impatiemment plus on passe à une dose
qui est obligatoire en quelque sorte
comment la colonnade bancaire à chaque
fois et ça ça impose polonais le bon
matériel or nous n'avions pas ça il faut
bien le comprendre
pour l'instant les médecins se
débrouillait bien souvent ils amenaient
leur propre aux aiguilles et parce que
les aiguilles qui étaient livrées par la
dgse direction générale de la santé
n'étaient pas les bonnes
or pour arriver à faire si dose il faut
avoir des aiguilles qui n'ont pas de
volume mort contrées peu de volume en
l'idéal étant d'avoir des aiguille
sertie d'un bep sereine et là vous
arrivez à le faire tranquillement à
chaque fleur mais ce n'était pas le cas
italien dans son communiqué la direction
générale de la santé dans le communiqué
qu'elle à sortir la pm je crois hier
soir nous dit que elle rassure tout le
monde
elle va donner le protocole les frères
échantillonnés pas retenu mais qu'elle
va aussi livrer le bon matériel n'est
que de la télé patrick plus tôt elle va
livrer le matériel
donc là on est relativement inquiet
parce que soit il est là sur matériel
mais à ce moment là elle pouvait le
livret soit ils ne la pas et on retombe
dans la problématique des masses comment
on va acheter des se règlent serti un
moment où la demande mondiale
on va se heurter à une concurrence
internationale et on risque de ne pas
être livrés donc non seulement on va
avoir des process qui aujourd'hui pour
être ralentis parce qu'on fait peser la
responsabilité des sigles aux sur les
équipes vaccinales qui vont être obligés
de faire extrêmement attention les
ennemis les 0,3 milito qui est donc vont
aller plus lentement parce que par
prudence on va faire c'est s'il ose et
on doit garantir aux patients qu'il est
bien maxi des dons combat s'il a moins
de patients à chaque heure mais surtout
on n'est pas du tout sûr que l'on
recevra la dotation en bon matériel et
donc au niveau relativement rapidement
je dois laisser le mot de la fin
philippoteaux ce genre d'information
tout de même est ce que ça n'augmente
pas encore plus la défiance de la
population vers les autorités dans là
c'est pas les autorités mais les
laboratoires
c'est vrai que ça ne donne pas confiance
à engendre une confusion et un climat
douteux qu'on fusionnant les gens
clairement on voit bien que tu as our
sur la vaccination depuis le début
notamment en france il ya aujourd'hui de
gros doutes sur la façon dont cette
campagne vaccinale est organisé
d'ailleurs les médecins généralistes ce
même se sont plaints d'être
insuffisamment associés on peut les
comprendre à cette campagne alors qu'ils
sont quand même la première ligne pour
les la plupart des françaises et des
français dans leur relation à la à la
santé ce qui est sûr c'est que on voit
bien que sur aujourd'hui cette question
de la vaccination
on a le sentiment de finalement
reproduire le mauvais film que l'on a
connues et le docteur martin a très
justement rappelé lors du début de
l'épidémie avec les masques puis les
tests la question est de savoir si
finalement au-delà des questions
industrielles qui sont réelles si l'état
a fait un véritable retour d'expérience
tels que sastre à tic dans les
entreprises en règle générale de
finalement des manquements qui ont été
les siens lors de la première campagne
si je puis dire de cette crise et on
peut se poser des questions en effet si
en l'occurrence on a tiré toutes les
leçons en matière d'organisation
de logistique pour justement aborder
dans les meilleures conditions cette
campagne de deux vaccinations
le mot de la fin pour vous philippe
tauzin puisque vous êtes près de la
frontière suisse de nombreux français
vont se rabattre en suisse
malheureusement peut-être
heureusement je ne sais pas pour eux
mais qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
quand on voit que ces stations suisses
restent ouvertes et que tous ceux qui
peuvent pas les skis en france et qui
n'en peuvent plus de ne pas pourvoir
prendre l'air vont aller skier en suisse
ce sera ma dernière question
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on voit les images
qui remonte des webcams de 10 attendant
les stations suisses on se demande
comment ça se fait que des pays laisse
quand même encore leur station ouverte
donc on râlait un petit peu maintenant
la clientèle qui va sur ses stations
suisses à lima par opportunisme on sait
qu'elle reviendra dans les stations
françaises c'est pas tellement sahin qui
qui nous fait souci aujourd'hui il faut
que la montagne pour ce mois de février
reste reste adaptable il va adapter avec
cette nouvelle décision il va falloir
montrer solidaires solidaire avec tout
tissu économique et social de la station
et puis responsable aussi également par
rapport aux gens qui voudront venir en
février les stations qui ont ouvertes en
suisse va en bénéficier d' opportunisme
dont je dirais tant mieux pour eux mais
il ya quand même les jauges les quotas
les restaurants ne sont pas ouverts les
bars non plus enfin c'est pas quand même
la panacée je connais le directeur de
verviers on discute avec si vous êtes
vous inquiet tu sais c'est pas quand
même le top
alors maintenant écoutez nous c est
actée ça serait une saison blanche pour
les remontées mécaniques mais mais la
montagne peut exister quand même février
on va attendre savoir si un confinement
ou pas si on pourra faire des animations
des activités qu'elle comme on pourra
séduire une clientèle en février à quel
moment pour essayer un petit peu
d'années de baume au coeur un peu à nos
futurs vacanciers
merci en tout cas bon courage à vous
merci jérôme martin merci également à
arnaud benedetti d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france